I did change my mind and allow him to
not only come to the wedding but to be
in my wedding
do I regret that yes that was really
heartbreaking to hear and very hurtful
it feels a little bit like a smear
campaign Tom and Tom inside
Tom Tom yes thank you the new side of
Tom Tom yes the expansion is officially
open
do you now each own 10% of this business
now that it's twice the size
yes let's wait until later on the season
yeah okay is that you can see us we
knocked through to punch through from
the original side our baby to our she
take some aggressions out yes with a
with a tiny little hammer some small
aggressions well I could understand
having some aggressions to take out at
least for us-- and of all because it's
been a tough season so far probably seen
there's been a lot of ups and downs hey
hold up there big guy I'm hanging in
there I'm hanging in there and thank you
for asking you sure yeah yeah you know
obviously a lots happened I even said
that coming into this season that is
going to be a roller coaster ride and
the funny thing is is we are just
getting started so yeah that's a little
scary because so far I feel like you're
getting labeled like a pot stirrer
interesting I feel like we know we're
doing our job in the sense when you talk
about the one thing you don't want to
talk about I mean that's kind of the way
it works the pot-stirrer thing I think
you're getting it from both sides though
where it's like good and bad like the
whole Stassi moment I thought the
audience was like not a great look no of
course I mean I should have never sent
that text message and I think you know
it wasn't even necessarily so much like
a rage taxes it was like a stress text
of me of like finally redefine it yeah
so so intensive rage well you know the
ending was very you know aggressive yeah
okay sure saucy we've learned a lot from
that experience you know yelling in the
middle of TomTom and you can fit a
little in somebody in scolding them I
mean anybody who does that whether you
know whoever they are would normally be
escorted out normally but we didn't have
a door guy that day no but you know what
I'm saying the flipside I do feel you
bringing the whole pastor issue with
Brittney and Jax's wedding has been well
received by the audience and the pastor
that you had until like three days ago
right I'm wondering like why it took
Lisa coming to you guys I'm not talking
about this are you is that it kind of
bothered me that when talking to other
people about this like other cast
members other friends that were there
you know they had the similar concerns
and questions and then you know when I
pulled Jax aside and ask him a question
which adjustment to be between me and
him just have that quick conversation be
done with it and then it you know he
gets up and like turns it into this
whole thing you know why do you think
you were the only one who spoke up and
said anything it's not easy to ask those
questions
it wasn't easy for me to ask Jax about
that especially knowing how reactive he
can be it was very important to me to
ask that question to to find out to hear
like what he had to say and it's
unfortunate that I never got to hear it
you do kind of apologize to him for it
turning into such a big deal what would
you take back that apology no I did feel
bad about it I didn't want it to turn
into that at all I I feel bad about that
that was like the last thing I wanted
this is maybe the first time in our
relationship where I'm having a hard
time seeing where you're coming from I
guess he has random to me and the
so stand in your place a new schwarz get
caught in the middle here yeah how do
you say yelled I know well yeah how do
you feel about it I was giving him the
benefit of the doubt given how close he
was to his wedding I assume they're
handling it in their own way it's a very
private issue obviously I had feelings
on what he said so dime discussed about
what the pastor said I don't agree with
that sentiment when it was initially
happening and during the moment I was
siding with Jax cuz I thought it seemed
like he was putting him on trial without
all of the information so I thought
there was a lot of speculation but yeah
having seen it now I just I don't know I
don't know do you know I don't know no I
still need more information what
information are you missing all of it
okay yeah but that action did lead to
you being taken out of the wedding
we know you were eventually reinstated
because you were there but Jax in my
last interview with him about a month
ago said he regrets reinstating you that
was really heartbreaking to hear and
very hurtful it feels a little bit like
a smear campaign because when it did
come to the wedding I feel like I went
above and beyond to to prove my Worth
and all and I also enjoyed doing it I
don't know why Jax will regret we had an
amazing time I felt like I added to the
experience that's the one thing I really
wanted to add to the experience whether
it was just making his wedding a much
easier time more fun experience less
stressful I felt like I did that I felt
like I accomplished that goal and after
that we were in a really great place so
what's changed between then and now well
I think you're just gonna have to like
watch the show we're just getting
started with your you're at last
interview with Jax I'm just curious to
say if he was here now if he would still
stand by what he said before I feel like
he was fired up and he did I'm not
defending him it's been months of like
literally every
interview Jax does really basically
saying that Ariana's a nice relationship
is a sham you know that he gets very
reactive towards the end of our season
and because of that now he's trying to
justify that I feel like so that's why
when I say a smear campaign he's like
trying to slowly peck away at like Who I
am is a person my integrity like what
like even doing nice things for people
he's like all he only does that like so
he knows something bad is coming that
we're gonna watch and he's trying to get
ahead of it by making you look bad yes
okay that's what it seems like after
knowing Jax for twenty years
Ariana told me she would be okay never
having to interact with Jax ever again
how do you feel about that I don't know
how I feel about that I'm like I guess
I've been through worse but I don't ever
deal in absolutes
yeah so currently I'm not a fan because
of how aggressive he's been on every
front lately but you never know I mean
as a close friend there's part of me
that wants to reach out to him but I do
what are you doing you're spiraling on
Twitter you're going after him it's
feels unjust and out of line but you got
to let him figure it out for himself
when was last time the three of you I
actually hung out and had that quality
time it's been wasn't that long ago he's
like maybe a couple months three to
three months ago
you guys haven't really sat down I don't
know if you guys ever will sit down and
really hash it out and get in like
resolve this I hope you do yeah do you
want to do that it's really tough with
him it's really tough to get him to see
like actual reality instead of like just
like his sort of warped like propaganda
reality so in a world where you knew he
would hear what you were saying you'd be
down to do it yeah okay I guess I'm you
know I know better though I know better
sometimes it's just better than just
like whatever I think that's what we end
up doing with Jax a lot we're just like
okay but how many times can you do that
before you get to the point where you
say I can do this that's the question
that's that's that's a million-dollar
question
but you haven't hit that threshold yet I
don't know if I have bringing it back to
Ariana we also see in the most recent
episode Ariana told you she wanted to
leave her life I love you so much
but like Tom
I'm telling you I'm going to leave my
life I want to leave my life I mean
obviously it kills me to see Ariana's so
hurt and vulnerable and you know
obviously I'm here for her but feel like
you know in that group she doesn't have
like a safe space and it's frustrating
you know to see you know somebody like
Lala who's you know one second like okay
totally okay with like people saying
like very mean nasty things about Ariana
that are completely not true and then
talking negatively about her and then
like sort of getting emotional in the
same month this is a safe place it's
like girl you are not you are apparently
not a safe place she's always been kind
of weary as the gang in general she
loves us individually without a doubt we
all have great relationships with Ariana
but I feel like as a group as a whole I
feel like she's been we're he's probably
too strong of a word but she has mixed
feelings about the group as a whole
yeah since the beginning I mean she's
been honest that she didn't really want
to be a part of the show and all that in
the beginning and shied away from it
yeah last Arianna related question there
does seem to be a weird focus on her
sexuality
everybody is so dialed into her being
bisexual how does that affect your
relationship it really doesn't Ariana
and I love each other very deeply she's
like I would mean you broke up I would
probably end up with another guy I don't
think she really wants like us she
wouldn't really want like a long-term
thing I think it would just be like you
know
kilala in the car moment yeah I've eaten
one girl out besides you like like I'm
sorry [ __ ] but we're
can you clear the air with that because
I think people then question if you had
an open relationship or what was going
on there no not currently we did not
have a open relationship yeah have in
the past though I don't I mean I don't
know her and Lala hooked up in the back
of my car I mean I yeah who's open to
something
I just never deal in absolutes that's
why you know one of the reasons why you
know we're not necessarily into the idea
of like getting married so much I love
the celebration of it I like going the
weddings I like being a part of them but
doing a wedding to me seems very
overwhelming and intense and I get
overwhelmed when I'm around too many
people that I have really close to I
feel like I can't spend enough time with
any of them yes your head might explode
if you ever got married exactly exactly
speaking of weddings I think we're about
to see some confusing stuff between them
about your marriage
yeah I sort of uh way to swept something
under the rug this little thing called a
marriage license I didn't think you
actually needed it but we decided to
make the most of this and I don't know
how much I can say about it but it's
like one of my favorite moments well I
think we've seen little brief moments of
maybe someone in an Elvis outfit yeah
it's coming up it's coming up it's
coming out was one of the happiest
moments on the show and I've had a lot
of yeah it's something I'm very fond of
and I would love to gush about it right
now but I bet I should wave better than
the wedding in the woods no that was
that was an absolute dream come true
before then I just was honestly
indifferent to marriage but after that
wedding I would say I'm a fan I'm still
not a huge advocate you know don't let
people pressure you into getting married
although I will say that was the most
romantic I mean three days of my life I
had so much he had to wipe his tears on
the doll well my hands were full and
it's a soft dog I mean yeah and I'll
still throw on my my coat like maybe
once a month and I'll have like a
cocktail I mean Katie will reminisce
about it it was just it's a great jacket
it was perfect and I love the jacket too
Schwartz I keep hearing about this
Vanderpump rules pregnancy pact that
Katie Lala Stassi and Brittany all want
to have kids
that are the same age are we getting
ready for Bella babies I love kids I'll
make a baby tonight I'm down I'm ready
go for it that you won't I think I am
ready to have been I talk a big game in
it when it comes down to the brass tacks
actually making a baby I get cold feet
it's scary
once you're like really trying for kids
it's a major it's a major your life will
never be the same
I know I think I'm ready I've always
loved kids I just have never had any of
my own yeah a little worried but I think
I'm ready okay I wouldn't want to be too
old of a dad you know I want to be able
to cake play catch with my kids
it sounds like um Jackson Brittany will
be the first to try you want to try it
this was a tentative pact it's not a fit
at all nobody's in sign of blood but if
that happens I think they'd be great you
know okay I'm down I'm ready to have
kids watch oh you boy I'll just surprise
everyone didn't like have a cave before
everyone else do the twist of all twists
if you guys pulled the kid out
I'm kidding we're not looking don't even
start on that let's talk about the woman
who would give you kids Katie yeah she
Stassi and Kristen dealing with that
friendship breakup which is if we go
you moved in your perfect house cakes
are perfect husband and you're perfect
what else how are you guys navigating
being in this friend group we're two
people one your wife don't want to talk
or interact with one other person I've
seen it before
yeah it's play it's played out in every
different combination within that little
group of three but this time feels
different it feels more permanent such a
strong word I think I feel like we're
all just in different parts of our lives
I mean in that aspect it could be
something that is more longer lasting or
permanent you never know there obviously
we're in different parts of our lives
too that we were willed up on ages but
we're not necessarily a part per se but
we're growing up and we're maturing and
I think we're just becoming a little bit
more self focused and less like social
in the sense we still all spend a lot of
time together but like as we're back in
the day you go back to six seven years
like we were together like as a group I
felt like every day although maybe we
smile there to each other a little bit
in the beginning it seems like there's a
countdown to stassi's wedding of will
they or won't they invite Kristen if you
had to bet do you think she'll make it
there I know she's super busy she's
probably not putting a ton of thought on
whether or not Kristen will be there but
I honestly I'd say it's 50/50 okay
that's what she said it's a lame answer
but I see herself feels like 50 could go
either way more drama from this season
Sandoval you have long been a defender
of James Kennedy but in recent episodes
upcoming episodes he speaks to Raquel in
a certain way I need to get your take on
how he talks to his girlfriend yourself
her child he did not yeah he was he was
drinking I mean I think it's awful you
know I think James really struggles with
you know him and Jax are similar in that
way they can be very reactive you know
it's something that he should work on I
mean we all have things we we can work
on with ourselves that's sure not one of
James's strongest things and it seems
like he's almost too comfortable doing
it you know like it's something I'm not
saying I know he loves her I know this
I've seen them be super romantic and
cute and I know they care
a lot about each other but I feel like
you know and you know what maybe I'll
redirect that question myself there's
are the times where I've sent awful
things to Katy and you know especially
when you're drinking heavily James has
been sober no no yeah no no no yeah yeah
but yeah yeah it was painful to see that
but I know he loves her and yeah they
needs to work on that
he's work on his filters yeah he's had a
filter problem for a while yeah yeah
it's a whole growing up thing well in
different stages yes yeah he's yeah all
right you said mobile times a lot of
season left a lot of stuff that's gonna
surprise us what's gonna surprise us
there's so much more to go there's I
just don't even want to get into it it's
one of my favorite seasons and not
because it was enjoyable yeah the whole
time I've had people tell me that when
it was a tough season to film those are
the seasons they know are going to be
the best seasons to watch for sure that
is correct yes well even at that yeah if
you don't hate yourself at the end of
the season you didn't do your job
perfectly said
[Music]